HOST: The world is
full of amazing places,
both natural wonders
and man-made marvels.
But this place here?
This place is different.
This colorful, odd-shaped,
Dr.-Seussesque water spout
is actually a
little bit of both.
JARED ROPELATO: Hello.
My name is Jared Ropelato.
And I'm a photographer
from Vacaville, California.
This is a photograph
of Fly Geyser.
I had seen photographs
of Fly Geyser previously.
And I wanted to
see it for myself.
So I headed out, tried to find.
HOST: Fly Geyser is located
on the edge of Black Rock
Desert, the Nevada home of the
now world-famous Burning Man
Festival.
And the way it got its
name is a bit repetitive.
JARED ROPELATO: It's
called Fly Geyser
because it was actually created
on a ranch called Fly Ranch.
And when it started
erupting water,
that area flooded and
became Fly Reservoir.
And now sitting on
top is Fly Geyser.
HOST: And when Jared
says "created,"
he didn't mean by
some earthquake
or natural phenomenon.
It was made by accident
when a power company drilled
into a geothermal
pocket in the 1960s
and let loose a stream
of boiling water,
and with it, calcium
deposits, which gave it
that weird look over time.
JARED ROPELATO: Fly
Geyser is always changing
and always evolving.
It's sort of a living sculpture.
The bacteria and the minerals
that are in the water
create this colorful
crust around it
with terraced
landscaping all around.
And as more water shoots
out, pieces break off
and new pieces grow.
So it looks different today
than it did when I shot it.
HOST: And those
vibrant colors are
from something called
thermalphilic algae,
microorganisms that
thrive in hot water,
like the boiling hot
springs of Yellowstone.
JARED ROPELATO: The
first time I saw it,
I couldn't believe something
like this could even exist.
The vibrancy of the
reds and the oranges
and the yellows and the
greens, it's just remarkable.
HOST: And Jared
understands that it
looks too weird for some people
to even believe it's real.
It actually has its
own page on snopes.com.
But he also knows that within
that doubt may lie motivation.
JARED ROPELATO: Some people
might look at this photo
and assume that
it's fake somehow.
If I hadn't seen it
with my own eyes,
I might think the same thing.
I hope people that see this are
blown away, by not the photo,
but by Fly Geyser itself.
And I hope they're intrigued.
I hope they're curious.
I hope they wonder if
it's real or if it's fake.
And I hope that eats
at them a little bit
and they actually get out
there and take a look at it
for themselves.
It's just one of those things.
There's so much
beauty in this world.
There are s many crazy, crazy
things like this if you go out
and you find them.
Go see this thing for yourself.
You'll be blown away.
HOST: If you liked
this video, check out
this next one on the wild side
of Yellowstone National Park.
JONO HEY: We saw these
shadows in the mist
and started hurrying towards it.
And yet, you have this
joint feeling of like,
this is really exciting.
And these are bison.
And bison are really scary.
HOST: And as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.